chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett also attended the rally in
Orlando
he spoke exclusively with the man
running the president's reelection
campaign Brad parts kale major is this
rally a sign of things to come it is on
the positive and negative side let's
talk about the negative side this rally
this reelection launch was overshadowed
by a week of stories about leaked
internal polling data showing the
president trailing in many battleground
states then the campaign essentially had
to argue all public polling is
irrelevant and only the Trump campaign
understands how popular Donald Trump is
and what his path to reelection might be
that's a unique position to be in on the
positive side these rallies we're gonna
see at least two of them every month
this year many more as the campaign
intensifies and think of the rallies not
just as a political event but as a
portable data mining operation everyone
who RSVPs for a trump rally becomes part
of an ever enlarging Trump data set
already nearly a hundred million
potential voters that the campaign
believes is its technological advantage
I asked Brad parse kale about just that
yesterday as this campaign continues do
you win it with technology or do you win
it with the president first of all
president always wins it my job to get
the last point 1% the voter that maybe
didn't hear him get a little bit more
turnout up you know the president's
gonna win this I've always said the
president when the prime the the first
election Louie with his airplane and a
cell phone you know in a Twitter account
this time though we have to do some more
mobilization we have the power of
a-comin see and this time I have that
time and the opportunity and the money
to try to give him from point one
percent to that point two percent and if
I can do that that I've done a good job
here's a point about last night's rally
true a massive crowd nearly capacity
here in Orlando but about an hour into
that speech we noticed something I
hadn't seen very often before Trump
supporters leaving before the speech was
over after the speech the rallies site
cleared out quickly and there was not
that kind of intense pro Trump
enthusiasm I'd seen at previous rallies
for the duration of the event that
something that Trump campaign is
probably gonna have to pay attention to
that's interesting major the president
is facing 24 Democratic challengers at
this point major in in his re-election
bid how does that impact the campaign
strategy parts Cal told me that it
really doesn't matter who the Democrats
nominated that the party is lurching in
his word so far left that the president
can contrast not only his
accomplishments but the future
Democratic agenda whoever the nominee is
in such a way is to not only mobilize
hardcore Trump supporters but also
attract independents and some Democrats
so the campaign right now is only
looking at what it was describes as this
leftward movement of the Democratic
Party I asked par scale does Joe Biden
offer a sort of moderating effect on
that he said absolutely not the party
will pull by and relentlessly to the
left and it Fightin's the nominee he
said Trump can beat him in all of the
states that matter most in 2020 major
got it and can we just point out you
were not unusually short rad par skells
is very tall he's like six eight I know
Tony was pointing that out the table is
all Gail he is he is all of six eight
yes I know that makes me sort of doing a
little bit of this yes I thought that
was a good observation on Tony's part
major thank you very much